nice hey mr. Bremen I had a bunch of
messages for you but we had a system
crash about I don't know 20 minutes ago
and I'm still trying to find my files
it's one of those days i guess Sokka
I'll Las computer also having some
problems down in the test chamber to but
I think that's all straighten out
because I'm one per cycle the shower
Jordan is you've gotten to your had room
to give you a headset all right New
Mexico hello they need you in the head
okay give me my [ __ ] good morning dr.
raymond Lee earlier but the thermal
protection system seems to be online now
I guess TPS reports have gotten for
printer works hard to follow the hell
you lookin yeah bring it listen about
that [ __ ] head you're going to need
you to come in this one here holly [ __ ]
you know the g-man
hardly good [ __ ] a hold on hold on
let's check without one our time good
morning Jordan Agra morning give this
week now dad got big day today oh it
must have been do all morning shown
until after the explain I would suck on
your [ __ ] so hard or 400 k then yeah
yep there's a pepperoni pizza and my
near future how about batch there was
someone downstairs asking about you or
was it upstairs now I stop [ __ ] you're
living in the past that experiment is
single-handedly responsible for
inspiring my career and science how much
recognition do you think you're going to
get for reproduction though you should
focus on inventing something new and
unique he does have a point oh but this
is more than a replication I assure you
that the original study is published and
to say nothing of the modern perspective
necessary to monitor its influence I
mean find with today's technology I
recreate why I can't stand that your
headaches were this malarkey Montella
Larkin here's something to think about
well the next even if you would enjoy
other coated airsoft are absolutely
quality italo italo has been moving
across
Gordon I'm busy now our [ __ ] [ __ ]
hope you got fired today ok I can we're
[ __ ] here maybe later Gordon oh ok
hold it right there mr. Freeman I got
explicit orders not to let you through
without your hazards you [ __ ] dick
sauce I don't know I has not give you a
[ __ ] had it set us ssi all
displacement modulators were cute today
weren't they I sent here morning champ
back of my neck hello haha I trust this
morning find you well yes
ramblers Ramblers quavers naked fries
what's our health care again you think
you can fix the bending machine beeps
match outfits that was that would you
know who's much shut the [ __ ] up you
[ __ ] stash house they've been paging
you all morning dr. Freeman let's get
downstairs before you cause any more
disaster shut the [ __ ] up betch why do
we all have to wear these ridiculous
ties and these ludicrous penny loafers
am I said
welcome dirty hefe my 415 feet for you
inhabited entirely
thank God
[Music]
ok what does the music
how can hear that glad too long as I can
fly a bench check out this way that I
haven't checked over here yet holla
holla we're all set for this weekend dr.
Gibbons is coming in to cover for you
splendid I had we can talk at lunch ago
a comic can you forgot to carry that to
our enemies before us and hear the
lamentation of the women dr. Truman very
well to have about and buzzwords in his
research papers sex their faith set to
bake the law face yeah this is still the
wrong airlock I'm getting in here yeah
looking slick free moisture popsicle
warns really brings under eyes go [ __ ]
yourself you can't just suck a dick I
got chucks on a deck whatever you want
baby okay there we go here we go rocket
flying okay go right on through short
yeah stick your face in it like you're
in the box ask what's up man you're on
the barrel oh that's hi Gordon I don't
know myself in a rich [ __ ] I guess
I'm gonna
this place geyser oh shut shut someone a
mr. Freeman you gotta be [ __ ] kidding
me looks like you're running like you
are [ __ ] I know [ __ ] them on hold back
there you got a [ __ ] kidding me yeah
god I think Lachlan kidding me why is it
all so far away I trying to punish it
being an ass all right open up
yeah I caught the Palean how to suck it
up and up okay come on I'll bet it out
that hop it up
how about
hey mr. Bremen I had a budget mess yeah
yeah yeah good morning dr. Freeman hang
and Manning you're living in the past
that experiment is yeah-yeah-yeah
yeah-yeah-yeah yeah-yeah-yeah
yeah-yeah-yeah you all have to wear
these ridiculous are you guys ready for
the [ __ ] crazy music let's go [ __ ]
there's the music
[Music]
what are Bruce [ __ ] trippin with this
music [ __ ] traffic pocket memorable
you are used to pocket
[Music]
Bam Bam Bam Bam Bam Bam still down there
down there down there down down down
down yes yes dr. on my dead suckle on my
Terrace yeah lick maturi such a service
or useful yeah yeah any pictures of yes
time any pension it's got less
fluctuations hmm we should harness
remaining a photonic energy sure yeah
yeah yeahs sub doc stop we can talk
later Gordon natok leather patch I like
to talk to you work is supposed to be in
the test chamber half an hour ago Tamir
shut the [ __ ] up batch okay hello
Freeman Pat what is this all these
people just like not claiming [ __ ] I got
it ah Gordon there you are finally dr.
we've just sent the sample down to the
test chamber we've boosted the anti mass
spectrometer 205 percent bit of a gamble
don't we needed the end resolution the
administrator is very concerned that we
get a conclusive analysis of the sample
I gather he went to some lengths
together they're waiting for Gordon the
test chamber
right come on then I like a son of deck
come on John yeah put your [ __ ] acid
test eli has been busy making
last-minute preparations for the yeah
yeah man greetings July Lorna dizzy I
trust this wall yeah well or he dies
Gordon doing on this series I'm glad you
here have a club these last-minute
changes they're a bit strange just oh
it's about to go critical ah cat what in
the blazes is going on with our
equipment to do this nothing [ __ ] with
your bed right fight that crawls ghost
the radiation level is off the charts
I've got two PhDs and then erstad metal
that I find myself doing work best
suited for an environment clean you do
very meaningful work here really push
that button walk over here push this one
stand and stare at the screen walk back
over there push another button yeah well
now you're overreacting I don't know how
much longer I can apply these
[Music]
how about that oh there you are
everybody's been looking for you on
break there's all this stuff up shun
Thomas hey my chest nothing no time for
cold feet step right up ah here yes I'm
a highlight today I'm afraid we'll be
deviating a bit from standard analysis
procedure today Gordon yes yes but with
good reason this is a rare opportunity
for us this is the purest sample we've
seen yet and hang potentially the most
unstable not but his auto management
procedures everything will be fine don't
know how you can say that although I
will admit that the possibility of a
resonance cascade scenario is extremely
unlikely I just don't go who doesn't
need to hear all this is a highly
trained professional we will sure be
administrator but nothing can go wrong
ok I'll Alistair you're right Gordon we
have complete confidence in you Yellen
go get the name out there samachar he's
gay thanks for each other I am
is that about shock testing testing
everything seems to be in order oh right
Gordon your suit should keep you
comfortable through all this please
specimen will be delivered to you in a
few moments now if you would be so good
as to climb up and start the rotors that
way we can bring the anti mass
spectrometer to eighty percent and hold
it there until the carrier arrives okay
[Music]
and I'm very good we'll take it from
here allard to stage one emitters in
three two one I got
I'm seeing predictable savory
thanks to limiters activating
Gordon we cannot predict how long system
can operate with this level no evolved
meaningful day of please work as quickly
as you can
and Connecticut to 105 presenting class
myspace now it's probably not a problem
probably but I'm showing this small
discrepancy well it's well within
acceptable that just 80 people
we've just been informed with the sample
is ready for it should be coming up to
you with info about any delivery system
for your specimen
haha
standard insertion non-standard specimen
I can
took my a lot right now
yeah yeah it's good thing that lunch
break nap so I got I I could work
tonight
it's out for her Amish
[Music]